[Música]
hola y bienvenidos esta es la entrevista
de france 24 mi invitado de hoy es quizá
el mejor detective de arte del mundo
apodado 'el indiana jones del mundo del
arte
art brand ha pasado su vida rastreando
algunas de las obras maestras robadas
más importantes desde dallys hasta
pitazos se hizo famoso en 2015 cuando
recuperó dos estatuas gigantes de bronce
que eran unas de las favoritas de hitler
ahora relata esta fascinante
investigación en su libro los caballos
de hitler la increíble historia real del
detective que se infiltró en el
inframundo nazi
bienvenido a artur brand y gracias por
acompañarnos desde amsterdam
o la valeriana su libro es la historia
real de la búsqueda de dos esculturas de
caballos que una vez estuvieron fuera de
la oficina de adolf hitler cómo empezó
todo
bueno comenzó hace un par de años cuando
un amigo mío me silban recibió un correo
electrónico y este correo electrónico
decía que una vieja familia compuesta
por nazis estaba tratando de vender
algunas estatuas muy importantes y
pidiendo un par de millones por ellos
y adjunto a ese correo electrónico había
una imagen a color y en esta los famosos
caballos zarpazos y esos caballos eran
las esculturas favoritas hitlers y
adornaban la cancillería del rey que
estaban debajo de su oficina
así que reconocí estas estatuas y pensé
dios mío porque todos pensábamos que las
estatuas habían sido destruidas durante
el asalto de berlín en 1935 pero hoy
estaban en una imagen a color con dos
personas que usaban ropa moderna
entonces pensé bueno tal vez todavía
existen
como acaba de decirlo todos pensaban que
habían sido destruidas hace más de 70
años como logró localizar las
y bueno primero pensamos que eran
falsificaciones porque todo el mundo
pensaba que habían sido destruidas to
place resultado que hitler las había
trasladado al final de la guerra a un
lugar en el norte de alemania y los
rusos los confesaron cuando conquistaron
alemanes y las colocaron en secreto en
una base militar rusa y entonces allí
estuvieron los años 50 60 y 70
escondidas y cuando el mundo moderno se
derrumbó lograron venderlas a algunas
personas que aparentemente eran
simpatizantes nazis así que descubrimos
que los caballos eran de hecho los
verdaderos y empezamos a rastrearlo
mientras trataban de vender estos
caballos en el mercado negro
me hice pasar por un representante de un
comprador estadounidense que por
supuesto no existía y me inspiren jrr
guys de la telenovela dallas de los años
70 y 80
entonces el comprador era un barón del
petróleo texano con un sombrero grande
un hombre malo yo me hice pasar por sus
representantes como un posible comprador
ahí es donde empecé
el agua
durante su investigación que duró un año
y medio descubrió que durante la guerra
fría la estancia había comenzado un
negocio bastante rentable de vender a
arte nazi a occidente a menudo a
antiguos nazis o neonazis uniones
si los rusos habían confiscado mucho
arte nazi en algún momento en los años
70 descubrieron que en occidente había
gente que quería coleccionar los
entonces un comercio secreto entre
comunistas y ex nazis hicieron tratos
secretos para vender estas piezas había
un gran comercio de servicios secretos
como lograron incautar los caballos
bueno primero tuvimos que adentrarnos en
el mundo de este coleccionista si
conocemos a los nazis a la stasi incluso
nos encontramos con q trump pursuits
cuyo apellido de soltera era cubre un
himmler la hija de heinrich himmler y
toda esta gente estaba involucrada por
mi equipo con la policía alemana y
finalmente después de un par de años lo
queremos hacer algunas redadas en
alemania 600 agentes de policía
estuvieron involucrados y finalmente nos
encontramos
mi fan de
qué pasó con los caballos y otras obras
de arte nazis que recuperó donde están
hoy
bueno todavía están en un proceso
judicial el propietario dijo que se los
había comprado legalmente a los rusos el
estado alemán dijo que no había sido así
por lo que el estado alemán quiere
tenerlos de vuelta sigue siendo un caso
judicial pero probablemente terminarán
en un museo alemán
tal vez el año que viene con todas las
otras estatuas que encontramos porque
encontramos la mayoría de estas estatuas
que rodeaban la cancillería del reich
cuento ganó por este descubrimiento
pero me costó mucho dinero es difícil
cuando no encuentra estas piezas que
todo el mundo pensaba que habían sido
destruidas quien puede enviarle mi
factura a merkel así que al final me
costó mucho dinero pero valió la pena
fue una gran aventura estuvo en los
titulares de todo el mundo y por
supuesto ahora escribió un libro al
respecto así que es una historia
fascinante y también ha ayudado a las
familias judías a recuperar su arte
robado durante su carrera
los alemanes robaron miles millones de
obras de arte de familias judías y 70
años después de la guerra y algunas
personas dicen vale la pena que
recuperen sus piezas y serán todos estos
70 75 años estas familias judías nunca
tuvieron la oportunidad de recuperar
estas citas
así que estoy tratando de ayudarlos y
hemos encontrado piezas en el loop
incluso en la colección de la familia
real holandesa así que es algo que creo
que vale la pena buscar
[Música]
y lo han apoyado el indiana jones del
mundo del arte se compara con indiana
jones
no absolutamente no
indiana jones es un tipo que busca oro
yo ni siquiera tengo licencia para
conducir
pero tal vez algunas de estas aventuras
no sólo soy un tipo normal de los países
no sé buscar fondos también ha ayudado a
recuperar otras obras de arte famosas
puede contarnos un poco sobre sus otras
aventuras
hace dos años recupere un picasso una de
las pinturas favoritas de eficacia la
tuvo hasta que murió fue robada en
francia en 1999 densidad de al sheikh y
terminó en el inframundo de los países
bajos y logré rastrear el año pasado
recupere el anillo de oscar wilde un
famoso escritor irlandés inglés ya fue
robado de oxford hace alrededor de 20
años y lo recuperé en inglaterra y esos
son las curas de los casos que resueltos
el libro de caf es un poeta iraní muy
importante una de las copias más
antiguas del diván del siglo 15 que
había sido robado en alemania y yo
también lo recuperé en inglaterra
así que estoy trabajando en muchos casos
algunos resolví y otros todavía están
esperando a ser resueltos son más sus y
son austeros pueden subir shows anuar y
en qué investigaciones está trabajando
actualmente podemos esperar algunos
descubrimientos importantes en el futuro
si eso es pero hay muchas pistas
alrededor de 10 casos pero con la
situación actual con el hobbit para mí
es difícil viajar y muchas ganas de
resolver un gran robo o un museo en
francia tengo una buena pista y tan
pronto como pueda viajar iré y trataré
de recuperar los mercados estaremos
expectantes y alguna vez ha estado en
una situación peligrosa o ha tenido por
su vida
onlive
tuvimos bueno hay que entender que el
mundo del arte criminal es un mundo muy
peligroso en grandes cancers
involucrados mafias e incluso grupos
terroristas como el estado islámico así
que si a veces uno se pone en
situaciones peligrosas pero siempre digo
si sabes lo que haces hay una
posibilidad de que sobreviva y hasta
ahora incluso los dedos es sobrevivido
pero a veces puede ser peligroso
one last una última pregunta rápida no
se siente tentado a veces a quedarse con
algunas de estas magníficas obras de
arte que recupera
en áfrica donde siempre cuando recupere
ese picasso valía 17 millones por
supuesto tuve que devolvérselo a la
esposa del jefe pero lo colgué una noche
en mi pared y bueno es difícil tengo que
devolverlos en mi trabajo pero tuve el
anillo de dos oscar wilde durante dos
semanas en mi dedo y cuando tengo que
despedirme no es fácil eso seguro
muchas gracias artur brand por estar con
nosotros en france 24 y gracias a todos
por ver ese programa quédense con
nosotros para más noticias
[Música]